foreign
Scranton Pennsylvania hey Bill what's up
hey Dave thanks for taking my call
um my question is uh my wife and I have
been in baby steps 3B for almost two
years uh in that time we've been in the
same home we've had a second child and
you know the reason for being in 3D was
because our house was getting too small
but after all this time we kind of
decided that we you're going to stay
with where we're at and looking at the
route of putting on an addition during
that time we've uh saved up roughly
seventy thousand dollars and we have
about uh 150 of equity in our current
home that you know now that we're not
selling
is assuming you don't have access to so
just looking to see when can we
what's our best step to get that make
that home renovation in addition and
once we what are you going to spend on
the Edition
uh well the figure of the addition would
be roughly about a hundred thirty
thousand dollars
okay what's your story all right what's
your household income
uh my wife 150 000 and what's the home
currently worth today
uh roughly 300.
okay
so what do homes on your street
generally sell for
so we have one of the smaller homes in
our neighborhood and our street
um but houses range from 350 to 450.
and um you said your current home is
worth 300.
yeah yeah
okay I I would not renovate it I would
sell it
yeah I mean that's what we were our
original idea was two years ago it's a
better idea but here's why you're going
to spend two years of your life in hell
that's called a renovation
it's Purgatory it's right next door to
hell and
um it's not hell but you can see it from
there and you can hear it and
um on top of that when you finish if you
do a good job
with the design and that's most of the
time a big if because you're getting
ready to change this home by
30 to 40 percent of its structure right
uh that's such a large renovation that's
almost like building a house and the
chances of you doing that with good
architectural
when you're done the house isn't just
weird it's fairly low it's very hard to
do what you're doing well very hard
um and if you do it well and it all
comes out perfect after you go through
the two years of hell now you have the
most expensive house in the neighborhood
which is never where you want to be at
the top of the market so if I woke up in
your shoes I would sell that sucker and
I would go buy a house that's got the
stuff in it you want in a neighborhood
where you're in the middle or the bottom
half of the price range where you can
get the most future appreciation take
the equity out of your house and the
seventy thousand put it down take out a
15-year fixed rate where the payment's
no more than the fourth of your take on
pay and I would move to a 450 or 500 000
house you make enough money to do that
with uh 220 000 down payment for sure
and um guess what you don't have to go
through two years of hell
um because I got to tell you man
building a house is difficult building a
house while you're living in it
is grounds for divorce
I mean it's just it's it's cheese we can
have a big fight hanging curtain rods
building a whole no
no
I would not do it I I would not do it I
I am am I am I being clear about
advising against this before we before
we go to this next caller what are your
thoughts on renovating a home
yeah no sell your house man you know
I'll tell you the other thing is I we've
done light Renovations a couple times
like while we were gone on a two-week
trip or something they would come in and
tear out a wall and redo a bedroom and
change the carpet out and put Hardwoods
down or something like that I mean you
know but you know some substantial
Renovations but not not major knockout
entire things where you have to move out
of the house kind of crap
and um you know what happens about six
or eight months after I finish that we
move